Alright guys, so here is the final example and over here what you can see is we clearly
take out these relative equal highs here and we also form a frevaly gap, right?
And there's from this range low to this range high, there's only one frevaly gap and that's
on the 10 minute, okay?
So now I'm going to draw this out and I'm going to wait for price to close below it.
And just now, as you can see, we closed below it.
So now, this is going to be my take profit level as indicated by the fractals indicator
by Rachel T and I'm going to take my entry on the retest.
So if I put my shot position here, first off, I'm going to adjust my take profit level and
that is giving me one, two, one point four.
Now, as long as my stop is above the wake, I can get unlimited risk reward, right?
So it's giving me one point eight five.
So that is perfect.
Now look at the timing.
We are in the kill zone, right?
It is the, so we can also trade the strategy during the lunch breaks.
So usually there's a lunch break from five to six or from, you know, also, but it doesn't
really matter for the strategy.
You can literally just trade it.
So this is when we get the retests.
Look at this beautiful delivery that this is when you would be in the trade.
If I play this through, you're going to see that the take profit level was hit and probably
you could have targeted this low because that was a significant liquidity level.
This could have given you 2.45 risk to reward ratio.
So a very simple model.
You have to rewatch the video again and again until you understand this.
Here are some key notes that you should know.
So this is very important.
Listen very closely to increase the win rate of the strategy.
What you can do is you can identify one hour highs and lows.
So this is one hour time from now.
You look for any type of, you know, a sweep off the buy side or sell side.
So let's say on the one hour price takes out a buy side.
You drop down to five minute time from and then you look for bearish inverse
revenue gaps.
So you might see this on the five minute and you can see that we have another
buy side sweep and we're going to have one for value gap here.
We must have one for the gap inside there.
You can market the fair value gap.
Once the price closes below it, you go shot on the retest, target this level.
Now this is going to increase the win rate to some degree, but I haven't noticed
like a much significant difference, all right.
So you should be fine.
Also, if you if you if you've watched my SMT video and if you can use SMT with this.
So let's say on the DXY price failed to create a another higher high.
But on GPP USD, we do create a higher high.
Now, then the inverse for a gap is going to act even more strong and there's a high
chance there will be even higher chance that price will take out this low over here.
And make sure you stick to two to three pairs only because if you if you trade
every single pair, you're going to over trade and that is not good.
You make sure you only take two to three trades max per day with the strategy.
You do not have to over trade because some days, you know,
for what reason, God knows what reason, you know, every single trading strategy
can have a losing day.
So this can have it to start to minimize the losses, keep your maximum trades to two
or three and only choose two to three pairs or two assets.
This could be SMP 500 and that's 100.
This should be it for this model.
I hope you guys make good profits with it.
Of course, on a demo, I'm not a financial advisor, but make sure you practice this
first and try to trade above two minute time frame, but it works on all time frames.
All right.
And as I said, before, keep your trades two or three per day, not more than that.
Otherwise, the strategy will not work.
All right, let's move on to the next chapter now.